Today we are going to be discussing,
I'm certainly one of the biggest
bestsellers in early American history and
that's Thomas Payne's
pamphlet common sense.
Before I plunge in to common sense,
I am going to answer the question that
was asked from this section of the room
on Tuesday about how do you vote on
voting the little brain teaser of the
continental congress. And I found
the answer to this question. Okay.
So the answer to the question is they
actually had a pretty animated debate in
the continental Congress on
the whole voting question.
And some people said it should be
according to population and some said,
well you should put property
in with population. And
some people said one colony,
one vote and with after apparently
arguing for quite some time,
what they realized was they
actually really didn't have
an orderly way to figure
out population and property worse.
And so they also really just
decided one colony, one vote.
Like that's all we can do.
And they were really concerned because
they didn't want that to be a precedent.
Like they were all worried that they'd
be setting a precedent for all time.
So when they wrote it down in the minutes,
they said, we're deciding one colony,
one vote, but not with the idea that
it will be a precedent for all time.
Of course,
it then becomes a precedent for Congress
under the articles of confederation.
But the answer to the question,
how did they vote is apparently
someone made a motion. You know,
I make a motion that we just do the one
colony one vote thing and people just
voted on the motion as a group.
So that is the answer to the question.
How do you vote on voting?
I had not thought about it before
and yet historians have addressed it.
So there you go. So, okay. That
is the answer to the question. Um,
onto common sense,
which really,
truly unquestionably was a bestseller.
Um,
it actually sold over 120,000 copies
in its first few months in print.
And a little bit later in the lecture,
I'm going to give you a sense of,
of how that compares with how some
other things might've sold in this time
period. You'll really get a sense of
what kind of a bestseller this was.
And certainly many scholars consider
it to be the most brilliant political
pamphlet of the revolution.
Not necessarily for the
subtlety of its argument,
but certainly for the
way in which it's argued.
And I'll talk more about that
in the course of the lecture.
So what we're going to be looking
at is the pamphlet itself and what
specifically made it so remarkable.
And then we're also going to look
some at its author Thomas Paine,
who he was and how he came to
produce this influential pamphlet.
But I actually want to begin with
something that I just in my head,
when I think of that Thomas Paine,
I think about this.
So I feel like I can't start this
lecture without discussing it.
And that has to do with the death of
Thomas Paine or actually to be more
accurate, the body of
Thomas Paine. Okay. Um,
it's one of the sad ironies of history
that this person who all through this
lecture,
I'm going to be talking about,
the great influence of this pamphlet
had this great influence throughout the
revolution.
And he actually died pretty much poor
and not very much liked by Americans of
all political stripes,
more having to do with his politics
later in his life then what he was doing
during the revolution. But he was not a
happy camper in the years of his death.
But the,
the most horrifying thing about pain
Steph has to do with the question of his
body.
Okay.
So pain first asked about being buried
in a Quaker cemetery and the Quakers
weren't very excited about that because
they were not really hoping to have that
cemetery become a tourist attraction.
So that didn't work.
So he basically ended up at first being
buried on his small farm in upstate New
York.
A few years later,
a newspaper editor named William Cobbett
decided that what he was going to do
was disinter the body and
take it back to England.
And then in England they would
set up a memorial to Thomas Payne.
This was his plan. So he did, he
disinterred the buddy, he went on a boat,
he and did buddy pain,
went sailing back to England,
got back to England,
raise the issue.
And apparently did not get very much
support for the idea of a memorial of some
kind. At this point it
gets a little sad. Okay.
So not knowing what else to do and I
and why at this point he didn't think to
bury him someplace else.
I don't know.
But apparently he had the bones put in
a trunk and kept them on his farm for
awhile. Okay. So buddy of pain
sitting on his farm in England,
then he died it,
Mr Kovic died and the trunk and
pain was passed on to his son.
And then his son I guess went into debt
in some way and his belongings began to
get auctioned off and the person doing
the auctioning didn't want to have
anything to do with
auctioning off a buddy.
It's like I'm never
auctioned off a body before.
I don't want anything to do with this.
And basically pains corpse disappeared.
We really do not know
where Thomas Paine is.
I mean truly like there was a trunk and
it had pain in it and then it vanished.
And I went searching today before I gave
this lecture, trying to figure out like,
okay,
maybe there's been a recent development
in the search for Thomas Payne,
the corpse. And No, actually,
although I did discover that in 2001,
um,
there was a society that wanted to create
some kind of memorial here in America
and they decided they were
going to try to trace the body.
So they set out trying to trace the body.
What they found was all over the world
are people who claim to have a piece of
Thomas Paine,
right?
Well his skull might be in Australia
that his leg that might be an England.
So this sort of horrifying enter Thomas
Paine is his body disappeared and
perhaps a little pieces of Thomas Paine
or are flooding around his little relics
all over the world. So, so that's
pain, sort of weird ending,
certainly not the kind of ending that
you would wish for the person who has
written the pamphlet we're going
to be talking about today. Um,
and we are given that, you know, what
he ended up writing was so influential.
It's so different from much of what
was being written at this time now.
As I said at the outset,
um,
it's not this great subtleties of its
argument that made it stand out and in
fact its popularity was due to the very
things that were its greatest strengths.
The fact that it was passionate,
the fact that it had a really simple
style that it spoke to the common man that
it captured and completely overturned
prevailing colonial ideas about the
relationship between the mother
country and the American colonies.
As someone wrote at the time,
pain spoke a language which the
colonists had felt but not fought.
One of the remarkable things about the
pamphlet is that it was written by a
somewhat bankrupt English course maker
a mere 14 months after he had arrived in
America from England.
Basically speaking,
pay knew relatively little about colonial
affairs when he decided to write it.
He wasn't really an established writer.
He had done writing before.
I'll talk a little bit about this today,
but he wasn't this sort of well
known and established writer.
He wrote some for newspapers.
And actually the idea for the
pamphlet initially wasn't really his,
he wrote it at the encouragement
of Dr. Benjamin Rush.
I mentioned that in the first lecture
and I'm going to come back to that too.
So pain is relatively new to the colonies,
not really an established writer.
So how is it that he ends
up writing this pamphlet?
Well more than anything else,
it actually was pains,
experience of events in the
colonies between 1775 and
1776 that inspired what he
wrote.
Now let's look for a moment at bout to
see here what pain is experiencing in
that year before he wrote the pamphlet,
what is happening around him.
I'm going to talk about this
really briefly here because
I'll be talking in more
detail about this on Tuesday.
Um,
but one thing I will mention here very
briefly is part of what happens between
1775 and 1776 is the meaning of
the second continental Congress.
And that actually begins meeting
in the spring of 1775. Um,
I'll talk about the details of
the congress Tuesday. For now,
I'll just talk about the general
mindset. Um, for one thing,
no colony instructed it's delegates to
this second continental Congress to work
for independence.
That was not the agenda delegates.
We're pretty much still acting under
the assumption that they were trying to
force parliament or the king or someone
to acknowledge their liberties and
readdress their grievances.
And the overall assumptions still was
that balance had been thrown off within
the British constitution and
it needed to be rebalanced.
So they're talking about trying to
figure out a way of balancing things,
maybe a new balance,
but they're not talking about
throwing the entire system aside.
Actually in the minds of many of the time,
they probably were thinking,
why destroy what had for a very long
time been one of the most successful
political empires in the world.
John Adams noted in his diary at the
opening of the second continental congress
that at what he called an
elegant to supper, um, at
the opening of the congress,
many representatives and
their friends toasted quote,
the Union of Britain and the colonies
on a constitutional foundation. Okay.
So that's what they're hoping for.
As this congress opens
as an example of this initial
mindset of a congress, again,
more about this Tuesday
moderates attempted one last
stab at some kind of basic
reconciliation with the crown and they
issued what came to be known as the olive
branch petition.
It failed for a number of reasons.
I'll again more next week.
One of the most basic reasons being the
king refused to read the olive branch
condition, which pretty much is the way
to guarantee the failure of a petition.
By doing that,
the king basically gave some credence
to the views of the more radical members
of the continental congress and radicals
got even more credence on August 23rd,
1775 when the king issued a proclamation
that declared the colonies to be in
rebellion and then made plans to send
20,000 British troops to the colonies,
including Prussian mercenaries.
Okay.
Big Change and things much
more detailed Tuesday.
But this is important to
the setting of common sense.
So the king ignores the olive
branch petition. He sending troops,
not just any truth, but
literally hired guns, right?
Foreign hired guns to go to the colonies.
So the colonies have now been declared
in rebellion and army is coming.
At this point,
the con is realize that they need to
maybe take some form of action and make
some kind of military preparation,
not in an aggressive way,
but certainly in a defensive way.
Even as they began to do this and try
to stock up on military supplies and
engage in militia training,
still a lot of colonists considered
it pretty unlikely that a string of
relatively weak,
prosperous as they were colonies
could hope to defeat England,
the most powerful nation on earth.
And even if they did miraculously
somehow manage to do that,
certainly also most people in the
colonies would have assumed that instantly
foreign powers would have come zipping
over to North America and would've
swallowed up these
helpless little colonies.
And so now instead of
belonging to England,
they would have belonged
to France or maybe Spain.
So certainly things weren't really feeling
really optimistic at this moment in
which things seemed to
be dramatically shifting.
And this is the setting in which
pain wrote common sense in his mind.
The time was right for some kind of a
drastic change for the better in the
American colonies.
And as we'll see,
instead of just tinkering
with the English constitution,
paying basically turns his back on,
it rejects King George the third rejects
parliament and ultimately rejects even
the idea of monarchy.
So instead of centering on
the British constitution,
pain based his ideas about colonial
society and government on natural rights
logic,
arguing that the colonies should join in
a new government grounded on equality.
No,
obviously ideas about natural rights,
natural rights talk isn't new pains.
Achievement was to take those
kinds of ideas and in a sense,
give them to ordinary people.
Part of what he argues in his pamphlet is,
this isn't some great hi
constitutional argument.
This is about you and me
and life in the colonies.
And as we'll see in
method and in audience,
and an argument for all of these reasons,
pains,
pamphlet had a big impact.
So let's look for a moment
at who this man was.
Who wrote this early American bestseller.
Well,
he was relatively poor.
He was never really well off.
Obviously he was an intelligent,
strikingly intelligent person.
He was someone who loved to
assert his own importance.
He loved to brag about
his great accomplishments.
He loved to dominate a conversation.
Um,
it's possible towards the end of his life,
he may have had a drinking problem.
I tried to get authoritative word on this.
It probably don't even realize that.
Like when I'm, I all, I've
taught this course before,
before I give every lecture,
I actually go over it and kind of
Redo it and then I researched things.
So before I come to class,
I'm actually having these random,
it's like a big game of trivial pursuit.
Was Thomas Paine really drunk research.
Research. Research. Okay. Maybe not
so much what happened to the body. Oh,
we still don't know. Okay. Okay.
So I have these weird
trivial pursuit moments in
preparation for the course here.
So maybe drunk, maybe not slight drinking
problem. Historians disagree either way.
He was born in England in 1737.
I'm supposedly,
the cottage that he was born in was
literally in the shadow of a place of
execution.
So the dark hand of the state was
looming over the cottage of Thomas Paine.
Um, he was born poor. His
father was a Stainmaker pain,
did go to grammar school and he
liked learning. But at the age of 12,
he was pulled out to be apprenticed
to his father as a young man,
he had a number of different trades. Um,
none of them were enormously successful.
Um, I think for a little while
he might've been a sailor.
I think he was a minor office holder.
I think he was an excise man
in England for a little while.
In his spare time he liked to go to
public lectures in London and that's where
he met men like Benjamin Franklin.
And Franklin ultimately proved important
to pain because pain ended up doing
what a lot of sort of vaguely rootless
people in England might've decided to do.
He decided to try his luck in the
American colonies where there seemed to be
some opportunity for self promotion for
sort of making something of yourself.
But before setting off pain did an
intelligent thing and that is he made an
appointment with Franklin and
Franklin did an important thing.
He wrote a letter of recommendation for
pain and a letter of recommendation in
this period was, was kind of a magical
thing because if you think about it,
I mean unlike now where there are 5
million ways in which we all can check on
each other,
there really weren't ways in which one
person knew anything about a stranger or
could verify or check on who
some complete stranger was.
There's a reason why the early 19th
century is the age of the con man, right?
It's really easy for someone to drift
into town, claim to be somebody.
No one has a way of checking and then
the person can drift out taking various
amounts of money and belongings with him.
So letters of recommendation were
kind of magical because basically they
represented one person vouching
their reputation for another.
The person who wrote it said, I
writing this letter for Mr Pain, I,
Mr. Franklin writing from Mr Pain and
I'm introducing him to your attention and
wish that you will introduce yourself
to him and show him around Philadelphia.
Seemingly a basic statement. But
Franklin was basically saying, I'm,
here's my reputation. I'm vouching
for this guy. So you could,
you can get to know him, you can trust
him because I'm recommending him.
So it was a smart move on pains part.
It was a nice thing for Franklin to do.
And in the letter that Franklin wrote,
he referred pain to his son and son
in law, Richard Bache in Philadelphia.
So pain arrived in America in late
1774 but apparently the whole overseas
passage was pretty horrible.
So he was pretty much out
of commission until January,
1775 and at that point
when he was up and about,
bache offered to introduce him into
the local literary and political scene.
Now,
what happened next is a really good case
for the importance of serendipity and
the importance of bookstores.
Okay.
So pain liked to hang out
in this one local bookstore.
Apparently he went there every day
and that's the local literary scene,
the bookstore.
Um,
and he befriended the owner of the
bookstore and the owner eventually invited
paying to be the editor of a new
journal that he wanted to start,
that he was calling the
Pennsylvania magazine.
So Payne wrote for the
Pennsylvania magazine for a
while and he wrote a bunch of
different kinds of things. He
wrote fiction, he wrote essays,
he wrote social commentary as an
example. He wrote a piece on, um,
British cruelty in the East indies in
Africa and against native Americans
writing quote. When I reflect
on these examples of cruelty,
I hesitate not for a moment to believe
that the Almighty will finally separate
America from Britain,
call it independence or what you will
if it is the cause of God and humanity.
It will go on.
Now considering I'm going to talk a
little bit more about the fact that people
aren't really talking about
independence at this point.
So that's a pretty bold
statement before common sense.
Now,
one thing was noticeable about pains,
writings and that is that when they
seem to strike at issues of American
liberty,
even indirectly,
even seemingly through metaphor as in
one essay that talked about British
domination of India,
but everybody assumed India must
really be the North American colonies.
Whenever he was referencing any of
that sort of thing, sales jumped,
everyone wouldn't want
it to read those essays.
And ultimately it was some of those essays
that brought pain to the attention of
Benjamin Rush. Rush went to that same
bookstore, the magical bookstore,
the center of paints life.
Um,
he happened to meet pain
at that same bookstore.
So the moral is it's a good
thing to hang out in bookstores.
And through their conversations,
rush later wrote that at the
time he observed that quote,
pain had realized the independence of
the American colonies upon Great Britain
even at that time.
And that he considered the measure as
necessary to bring the war to a speedy and
successful issue. So he meets pain and
one of the things he notices is, well,
this guy is already kind of
thinking about independence.
Pain himself later wrote about his opinion
of the colonies upon his arrival and
he said that the thing that most struck
him was how loyal the colonists were to
Great Britain,
and this is Paine's words here.
I found the disposition of the people
such that they might've been led by a
thread and governed by a read.
Their suspicion was quick and penetrating,
but their attachment to
Britain was obstinate and it
was at that time a kind of
treason to speak against it.
They disliked the ministry,
but they esteemed the nation.
I think that's a really important point.
They disliked the ministry,
but they esteemed the nation.
Their idea of grievance operated without
resentment and they're single object
was reconciliation.
I viewed the dispute as a kind of lawsuit.
I suppose the parties would find a
way either to decide or settle it.
I had not thoughts of
independence or of arms.
The world could not then have persuaded
me that I should be either a soldier or
an author. Ultimately it was the
battle of Lexington that changed pains,
view and his life has changed
that of many others as pain.
Put it when the country into which I had
just set my foot was set on fire about
my ears.
It was time to stir.
And so it's at this point that pain begins
to tinker with the idea of writing a
pamphlet.
And apparently he spoke with Benjamin
Rush about it and rush later recalled in a
letter to a friend that he offered pain,
one overall piece of advice at the
outset of the project, he said to pain,
there were two words with she should
avoid by every means as necessary to his
own safety and that of the public.
And the two words were independence
and republicanism. Okay.
What you think about common sense?
He didn't listen to that advice at all.
And it's a matter of fact,
it's impossible to know what went
through pains mind at that moment. Um,
he certainly, he knew the colonies
were, as he put it on fire,
he knew that popular sentiment was
building even against the king.
But knowing his personality, it's entirely
possible that if rush said to him,
whatever you do, don't mention
independence, that pain's
reaction might have been,
well that's at the center of it,
isn't it? So that's it. Like that.
That's going to be what I write about,
isn't it?
It's going to be independence and he
might have deliberately done the precise
thing she was asked not to do.
Um,
and focus on the most controversial issue
that seemed to be at the very heart of
the controversy that seem to be certainly
to pain lurking right underneath the
surface of this prevailing
constitutional argument.
So Paine wrote the pamphlet,
he read parts of it to rush as he did
and common sense is published in January,
1776 and I did state correctly earlier
that he wanted to call it plain truth.
And Benjamin Rush thought
common sense was a better title.
And I agree with Benjamin Rush. I like
common sense better. Um, the pamphlet,
the main argument of the
pamphlet did three things.
So number one,
it basically refuted the prevailing
ideas against independence.
It went one step further and demonstrated
the necessity of independence.
And how possible it was and
it demonstrated the stupidity
and utter uselessness,
not only of the English monarchy,
but just have monarchies generally.
This is a radical message and it was
written in a radically simple style aimed
at being accessible to a broad audience.
This was all the more radical given that
American independence had not really
been seriously discussed by the
great majority of colonists,
with the exception of some extreme
radicals who I've been mentioning now and
again in lectures.
So let's look for just a minute it how
pain went through the three parts of his
argument.
And in a sense there's,
there's three parts of his argument and
the pamphlet itself has three sections
and the first section of the pamphlet
centers on getting people past this
ongoing constitutional argument about
the proper relationship between the
colonies and the mother country.
And to accomplish this painted
something amazingly bold.
He just tossed aside the entire idea of
focusing on the English constitution as
the context for determining
the fate of America.
And rather than going on and on and on
with the same constitutional debate,
he began his pamphlet with an attack.
Not only against King George but also
against the entire idea of monarchy and he
had a couple strategic reasons
for choosing to do this. First,
the crown was the last remaining emotional
and political link that was really
tying the colonies to the mother country.
By this point,
the colonists had lost
faith in parliament,
so pain certainly knew that if he could
strike at this last linchpin of colonial
sentiment, he could advance
the cause of independence.
Second,
if pain could destroy the legitimacy,
not only of King George but also
of the idea of monarchy overall,
then they English constitution
legitimacy would suffer as well.
Once again hopefully opening
the way for independence.
And then third,
I think equally important rhetorically
pain had a really good writer sense of
pacing and he knew that if he opened
this pamphlet with this really dramatic
challenge to all of the prevailing
assumptions about government and if you
turned all of these
assumptions on their head,
he would pull readers in to his pamphlet
and into his argument immediately and
hold them there for the
center of his argument,
which was the second section of the
pamphlet and that is really the part that
focuses on independence.
Independence at this point was a topic
that people didn't discuss openly.
They didn't talk about it in
public if discussed at all.
It was discussed privately among
friends because basically it amounted to
treason pains,
dramatic introduction opened the
way for him to introduce this really
controversial topic.
If the English constitution
lacked legitimacy, well what next?
And his answer obviously
is well independence,
the obvious solution which then brings
us to the third section of the pamphlet
and that is the future pain concludes
the pamphlet by discussing just what
Americans could institute to
replace the English Constitution.
Like what kind of government they might
be able to construct to replace what
they were stripping away.
Now throughout his work,
pain hammered away at old
ideas and propounded new ones.
He argued that America was distinct
from England, that it was multicultural,
that it actually was more the child
of Europe. Then the child of England,
he promoted American commerce.
He promoted social mobility.
He praised the innocence of the new
world is compared with the corruption and
decadence of the old world.
He struck at the trappings of monarchy,
things like hereditary
privilege and court intrigue.
He was an individualist arguing that
society was made of individuals who should
all be able to strive for their own good.
He wasn't arguing that families are
patron client relationship should define
society any longer.
He depicted government as a kind of
necessary evil that was prone to create
bureaucracies and privilege as he put it.
Government like dress is
the badge of loss innocence.
So it's the price we pay for being flawed
beings and he seemed to speak of an
American millennium. Speaking of
America as God's chosen people.
Pain argued that America's success was
linked to the success of all humankind.
That the American colonists could launch
a worldwide democratic revolution.
And as he put it up,
voted again.
But I think maybe it was the
first lecture that I quoted.
This is my sort of random inspirational
sentences from random guy from the 18th
century. Um, this is where
this comes from. It's, it's uh,
the statement about beginning
of the world, a new, um,
we have every opportunity
and every encouragement
before us to form the noblest
purists constitution on
the face of the earth.
We haven't in our power to
begin the world over again.
The birthday of a new world is at hand.
It's like millennial talk there.
The power of the pamphlet wasn't just
in its argument or in specific points of
argument, but rather it was in the way
that it reversed prevailing assumptions,
pain,
forced readers to consider a whole new
way of looking at the impending crisis.
And it actually at the
entire imperial system,
he laid bare assumptions that had
led colonists to resist independence.
And then by exposing these biases
and holding them up to scorn,
he forced people to think beyond
what they had thought before.
So basically the old paradigm had been
liberty can survive among brutal and self
interested men only through a
balance of institutionalized forces.
So no one can monopolize,
monopolize the power of the state and
rule without opposition. So monarchy,
nobility, and the people have an equal
right to share in the struggle for power.
Complexity in government in
the sense is a good thing.
Simplicity allows for monopolization,
we'll paint,
argues complexity is not
a virtue in government.
It simply makes it impossible to
tell who is at fault. Pain charge,
that the complexity of
the British government was
designed to serve the monarchy
and the nobility,
that the king did nothing but wage war
and hand out gifts to his followers and
that this entire idea of British
constitutional institutional balance was a
fraud.
Now the boldness of this message becomes
clearer when you compare it with some
other pamphlets of the time,
many of which were aimed at
exploring difficult questions, right?
Constitutional issues,
and then coming up with recommendations.
Common sense isn't about exploring
difficult constitutional questions.
It aimed to quote,
tear the world apart.
This pamphlet did not have the
kind of rational tone and lawyerly,
precise logic and high scholarship that
you see floating through a lot of the
other pamphlets of this period.
And the tone was part of why the
pamphlet ended up being so effective.
Pain didn't use legal arguments,
he didn't invoke legal authorities.
He assumed that his readers would have
some kind of limited knowledge of the
Bible. He didn't use a lot of
lab. And then if he did use Latin,
he tended to follow it up
with an English translation.
He used really
straightforward sinked syntax,
a really simple vocabulary as he himself
explained it as is my design to make
those that can scarcely read,
understand I show,
therefore avoid every literary ornament
and put it in language as plain as the
alphabet. So what he wanted to write,
he said was quote, simple facts,
plain arguments,
and common sense.
Sometimes it was pains.
Irreverence in comparison
with other pamphlet writers
that made his writing seem
so effective. So, for example,
writing about the origins of the English
monarchy and William the conqueror.
Payne wrote,
no man in his senses can say that their
claim under William the conqueror is a
very honorable one,
a French bastard landing with an armed
band diddy and establishing himself,
King of England against the consent
of the natives is in plain terms,
a very paltry rascally original.
Okay. It's not your typical pamphlet.
Sometimes he used really straightforward
language just for shock value,
trying to make his point by trying to
upset prevailing ideas by saying something
in a shockingly straightforward,
in a reverent manner.
And that's obviously going to be really
effective if he's talking about the king
to use sort of shockingly
irreverent language. So for example,
he really tried hard to dehumanize King
George the third writing, for example,
he has sunk himself beneath the
rank of animals and contemptible.
He crawls through the world like a worm.
Okay? That's pretty irreverent language.
Even brutes do not devour their young.
Okay.
That would have been really shocking to
someone to read at the time that that's
a description of the king or he
used sarcasm as in this sentence.
Now I mentioned this sentence,
I in the first one of the early lectures
I talked about a sentence that um,
I really liked and I accused Benjamin
Rush of cutting it out of the pamphlet and
I'm here to redeem Benjamin Rush.
Cause when I looked this up
today to double check on myself,
what I discovered was this
is actually Benjamin Rush,
his favorite sentence and
Benjamin Franklin struck it out.
So it was in the draft and it didn't make
the final printed copy of common sense.
And this is the sentence. Okay. A
greater absurdity cannot be conceived of.
Then three millions of people running
to their sea coast every time a ship
arrives from London to know what
portion of liberty they should enjoy.
I think that's a good sentence. I agree
with rush. I think Franklin had it wrong,
I think. I think that's good.
Sort of point pointed sarcasm.
So I'm sorry I didn't make the final
printed version rushes right. So sarcasm,
effective or reverence, shock value,
all effective, even just emotion,
even pains.
Emotion was effective because it was so
strong because he was so passionate and
because he was so straight forward
as in a sentence like this,
everything that is right or
reasonable pleads for separation,
the blood of the slain,
the weeping voice of nature cries,
tis time to part. Okay. Dramatic,
passionate, emotional language.
So all of this stuff that I'm
describing here, all of this rhetoric,
all of this logic, all of the sort
of rationale behind this pamphlet,
this is popular culture,
but it's not low culture.
It may not have had
really refined language,
but it hadn't correct language
as Thomas Jefferson put it.
No writer has exceeded pain in ease and
familiarity of style in perspicuity of
expression, happiness of elucidation.
And it's simple and unassuming language.
Okay. By riding that Jefferson
achieved none of those things.
That's like a really good example of how
different pains sounded perspicuity of
expression and happiness of
elucidation. Okay. Not In common sense.
Jefferson does not sound like
Thomas Paine. Um, given all of this,
the widespread popularity of the
pamphlet isn't surprising and the first
printing sold out in a few weeks.
There were many reprinting
first in Pennsylvania,
then in other colonies and even
ultimately in Europe and all in all,
a majority of the population of the
colonies either read common sense or
received some kind of distilled version
of it at their local tavern or in
conversation as presented by
other people who had read it.
By march [inaudible] 1776 there had
been 125,000 copies sold and by colonial
standards,
that's a mind blowing number of copies.
And here's a way to sort of put that
in context at this period, even later,
even in the 1790s in a city
like New York or Pennsylvania,
a newspaper that would have been
considered to have like a big circulation
number like wow,
that's a really big newspaper would have
had a circulation of a thousand. Okay,
so 125,000 copies is a lot of copies.
That's,
that's a pretty remarkable number.
And sales were helped by the fact that
the pamphlet was priced really low so
that it could be bought by anyone, even
the relatively poor. Now, of course,
pain wasn't shy about
his own accomplishments,
and he later told anybody who would listen
that his pamphlet had enjoyed, quote,
the greatest sale than any performance
has ever had since the use of letters.
It's not a modest man. It is the greatest
selling thing of all time. It's like,
okay, okay, Tom, it's
important, but come on now.
Of course, not everybody cheered
with the publication of common sense.
There were many people who were enraged
at what it dare to say about the English
monarch, about the British constitution,
about independence. I mean,
who was this guy anyway?
Right?
Who was he to promote independence as
Samuel Adams put it with actually unusual
understatement for Samuel Adams.
He said,
the pamphlet quote has friended
some folks here more than a little.
It upset a lot of people.
More direct criticism was issued by an
English gentleman traveling in Virginia.
In his diary,
he wrote a pamphlet called
common sense makes a great noise.
One of the vilest things that ever was
published to the world full of false
representations,
lies calumny and treason.
Now, you may be surprised
to hear that John Adams,
ultimately a leading
proponent of independence,
did not like common sense.
John Adams did not like the pamphlet.
It wasn't because of the first two parts,
right?
He's all for questioning the British
constitution. He's all for independence.
That's fine.
But what really got Adams was the
third section of the pamphlet,
the section about like what
kind of government might
we be able to create in the
absence of the British constitution?
This made Adams crazy because two
atoms into many others at the time,
good lawmakers were supposed to always
be practical thinkers and they were
supposed to be realistic about
what a society could achieve.
They were supposed to think about the
realities of a society and then what would
be politically possible. And this is
not what he thought pain was doing.
He thought pain was sort of blue sky,
unrealistic tossings off
about possibilities without
thinking really hard about
probabilities.
So this is John Adams,
summary of common sense. Is it true
John Adams? Okay. Common sense quote,
a poor, ignorant, malicious,
shortsighted, crappy analysts mass.
Okay.
That's John Adams opinion of common sense.
I have to add here for no reason
except that when I was writing this,
I thought of it and then this is my
excuse to mention it in a lecture.
And so I will, um, how many of you
here have read Plato's republic?
Some of you have read Plato's
republic. Okay. Um, John,
I was really did not like Plato's republic
either and it for the same reasons,
right? He thought Plato was
irresponsible. He hated Plato's republic.
Jefferson was not a big fan either.
He thought that,
that actually both of them thought
that Plato was Sorta vaporizing about
political ideals and not really thinking
about realistic application to real
people.
So to these guys at this time,
the real challenge of what they're
doing is to match ideals and realities.
And they didn't think Plato
was doing that at all.
So this is what Adam's first had to say
about Plato's republic while waiting
through the whims,
ease,
the pure realities and
unintelligible jargon of this work.
I laid it down often to ask myself,
it could have been that the world
should have so long consented to give
reputation to such nonsense. Is this
okay? He really doesn't like Plato's,
but he also just didn't like Plato.
So overall he said,
he talks about how he read all of Plato's
works and he talks about, oh yeah, no,
three Latin dictionaries in a German
one and a French one just in case.
And he like worked his way through.
Uh,
and he said he learned only two
things from all of Plato's work.
He learned number one,
that Benjamin Franklin stolen idea
from Plato to give him credit.
I never too, he learned that
sneezing is a cure for the hiccups.
And he said quote accordingly,
I have cured myself and all my friends
are that provoking disorder for 30 years
with a pinch of snuff. Okay. That's
Plato to John Adams. That's it.
So I just loved it. I love that
John Adams and his best. Okay.
So away from Plato back to common
sense. Um, for many people,
common sense was kind of a conversion
experience. And there are people,
they're are fence sitters who may be,
might've had the makings of a radical
and in reading the pamphlet or hearing of
the pamphlet, they actually
were radicalized by it. It
was talked of everywhere.
As rush put it, its effects were sudden
and extensive upon the American mind.
It was read by public men.
It was repeated in clubs,
spouted in schools and in one instance
delivered from the pulpit instead of a
sermon by a clergyman in Connecticut.
It's a Connecticut woman.
Always happy when we have like
little Connecticut or Yale moments.
It was talked about everywhere.
It's rhetoric was so powerful that for
many it inspired them to stand back,
examine their situation and really low
the Britain for the first time like, oh,
I've never thought of loathing Britain
before and yet now I am at George
Washington wrote common sense was working
a wonderful change in the minds of
many men.
In the end,
regardless of whether one agreed
or not with his argument pains,
pamphlet did one
fundamentally important thing.
He focused the prevailing colonial
political conversation on independence.
He lifted the argument above
constitutional reckoning.
He inspired others to write about the
topic as well. Sometimes for independent,
sometimes against,
but independence became now the topic
to discuss as a reader in Boston,
put it independence a year ago could
not have been publicly mentioned with
impunity.
Nothing else is now talked of and I know
not what can be done by Great Britain
to prevent it now.
Pain was all too happy to remind anyone
who would listen about the significance
of his pamphlet.
He considered it his lifetime achievement.
He wanted his tombstone
to read Thomas Paine,
author of common sense of course that
was assuming he was going to have a
tombstone,
which
for guy and think of that
until the second bad irony. Um,
he said that regardless of whatever
form he took in the afterlife,
you would always know he had
written commonsense. Okay.
But did common sense cause independence?
Okay.
Pain clearly would have loved
to tell you that it did.
That's the kind of conclusion
you really can't make.
But clearly you can say it was
so powerful, so widely read,
so controversial that it shattered much
of the psychological resistance to the
idea of independence.
And also on a more social level,
common sense invited an entire range of
people into the political conversation
that in some ways hadn't
really been included before.
Just by deliberately making this pamphlet
available to as broad an audience as
possible and his message in a sense was
fundamentally democratizing as well.
Pain preach that any people can
deliberate and decide how they are to be
governed and then they
can act on that choice.
Any people are capable of creating
and implementing their own government.
It's a powerful message and regardless
of whether people agreed or disagreed
about what government
they should be creating,
the ideas underlying that pamphlet in
a sense we're really revolutionary in a
sense and certainly radicalizing just
at this moment when things are taking a
turn just at this moment when the king
was declared the colonies and rebellion
and very soon we're going to have
Lexington and conquered so you can see how
we're right at this moment where things
are going to take a shift. Common sense,
partly timing wise came out at just the
moment where it was going to strike and
have the broadest impact. That is all
I have for today. Have a good weekend.
I will see you on Tuesday and
we will move on to independence.
We get independence next week.
Very exciting.